hello everyone and welcome back to
nintendo treehouse live
i'm kaye and i'm here with rob riona and
brandon and we are going to show you
some gameplay
from mario party superstars this is a
superstar game because it's made of a
best of you know it's mini games and
boards from the past of the series
uh everything is on buttons and sticks
so you can play with a pro controller
with a
switch light whatever you need and let's
just get started
so if you remember the 964 bar the n64
board peach's birthday cake uh it was it
looked like this
and i think you'll see that the new
board looks a little bit tastier
just a little bit tastier yeah powdered
sugar it's in such high fidelity
i've never seen such detailed powdered
sugar
uh if you haven't played the series
before mario party is a board game
series
uh you run around the board trying to
collect stars you play uh mini games to
earn coins and the coins can be traded
for the stars
so that's the basic idea you'll see as
we go
and of course there's hijinks that ensue
on different spaces that you'll
see us demonstrate oh i said yes
it's not actually my first time playing
this sure we'll take a little tour
so over here we have the scary bowser
pudding
we're gonna leave it there we're just
gonna leave scary bowser putting us
hanging for a drama and as toad just
told us yeah the goomba
uh decides or helps us decide which part
we take
all right so let's um go ahead and tell
everybody who who we all are playing
uh i am rosalina i'm peach
i'm birdo
i'm luigi
[Laughter]
all right so we all get some coins to
start with and we're going to start
getting going on this board
it starts nice and even and it does yes
it doesn't last very long
and we're all friends right now you'll
notice yeah for now
uh this board is unusual because the
star is always in the same place you
have to get basically to the center of
the cake
on other boards the star moves around
each time someone collects it
so the strategy is going to be different
depending on which board you're playing
yeah
okay i'm going to roll my dice here
oh come on oh this is a great start oh
well
he's got this advantage going oh that's
true
so like i said hi jinx and sue on some
of the spaces this one is a
is one of those event spaces where you
can choose to plant a strawberry but
it's
a weird strawberry yeah
very special strawberry it's very
healthy looking
very hungry and yeah if any of the rest
of us land on that on one of those
spaces in front of the piranha plant
they will steal coins on brandon's
behalf yeah please feel free if you've
got
one three or four no three or four oh oh
did you say three or four i guess i did
i'm just doing this you know for you
guys at home to see what happens
educational value oh man yeah
already starting off not fair i think
it's going great oh no
get ready for bird domination
guys but i did not land on the piranha
plant that's true you did you landed on
well you landed on the blue space so
that's that's good for you because you
get coins yeah luigi
oh yeah oh look at that strong out of
the gates
[Music]
oh
well you're in good shape now because
you have enough coins to trade for a
star when you get there
for now so now we'll see which uh
messy oh boy oh no oh i agree
i have a great strategy for this game
where i say everything out loud so
you'll notice that uh
the the first thing it shows you is a
quick uh explanation screen where
everyone can actually
play the game a little bit but it
doesn't count yet as we all sort of
figure out how the controls work and
everything
uh and then once everyone is ready you
can hit plus or minus to uh say yes
let's start
so yes let's start yes let us let's
start
that's such a helpful thing the point of
the game is to remember where each item
goes brown
hammer no
mario luigi eggs
[Laughter]
yeah don't copy me that's helpful
because then there's
the curtain feature so as soon as i feel
like i have everything in the right spot
i can close the curtain and nobody can
copy me
my strategy was just try to pay
attention to the lower shelf only i
don't think i can manage the whole thing
i think i got the lower shelf right now
i don't actually fill in whatever i can
i think this goes here
i'm just going to arrange them okay
close the curtain no cheating
no cheating oh
as a quick reminder this game is still
under development so occasionally you'll
see
some uh whoops oh
little menus no
what happened brandon i was just trying
to double check myself
oh no before you double wrecked yourself
oh no oh no
it's going well so far i did not do very
well i did all right i guess
hey i got the whole lower shot right oh
no
my strategy failed me oh
[Laughter]
i don't know if you knew that turns out
sure i see how it is yeah wow
i'm sad already and it's only around
here yeah oh look how sad birdo is
i might have to express my feelings
[Laughter]
so it's a new feature in this game is
you can
you know put your stamps up there if
you're playing online with someone you
want to express yourself
there's a bunch of different stamps you
can use
or you can do it offline when you're
when your friends are right there on the
couch but you just feel like
throwing hilarious cartoon art up yeah
what
all right i love this one big numbers
big numbers
okay that's that's pretty good that's
pretty good oh
yeah oh i'll take it see how it is i'll
take it
give me something good that's pretty
much all right yeah yeah i'll take it
so items help on in future rounds you
can choose to use an item it usually
affects your role
or someone else's role sometimes well
some of them do other fun stuff yeah
ah yes i will be planting a alleged
strawberry
i just love looking at the whipped cream
like it just looks so tasty oh yeah
it believes it's a strawberry this board
always makes me hungry
yeah let's go
[Music]
oh probably more delicious during the
first round before everybody's walked
all over the cake
but it's still delicious either way
thank you for putting that image
[Laughter]
stick to the path everyone
don't get lost in the frosting all right
all right it's on now
okay hammer drop this one's a coin game
so we all get to keep whatever we
we earn during the game i like these
because they become extra chaotic
yeah i just apparently walked off the
stage immediately i didn't
see where i was the bold strategy yeah
yeah so obviously i know what i'm doing
ready yeah great i love that practice
round is so useful okay
yeah the hammer stuns you for a second
so it's really bad oh
hit by one oh not like that don't don't
do that no
oh no oh no i forfeit i forfeit
what happened brandon i got
now you see how i sharked you i walked
off the stage immediately during the
practice
let's put some money on the next mini
game no thanks
but five coins
okay here we go this is the one it was
nothing
it was
[Laughter]
all right i'll take it these are great
you never know what you're going to find
you can even get a star out of those
there's lots of fun surprises like this
on on every game board
it's really difficult to uh you know
predict a winner with this game
it's part of what makes it so fun yeah
all right
double dice double dice how it's done
or don't why because why
why does this always happen to me pickle
masters
oh boo oh really really
show off
i don't know what for
all my various crimes i know it's
brandon we have to watch out for look
how many coins brandon has
no don't look at that that's fine yeah
look how delicious the cake is pay
attention it is a good cake
all right here we go i'm gonna trade my
20 coins
for a delicious star and shoot up into
first place
for now for all
i mean you see there's at least two more
people coming who have enough
coins to trade so well done i mean look
at this turn we know who the real
superstar is
you know you just keep telling yourself
sorry i couldn't hear you all the way in
fourth place
i deserve that man i deserve that
so this is a one versus three because i
live in a different kind of space as
everyone else oh okay
this one so this is the one where i try
to squish all my friends rocks yeah
oh no like that yeah okay i've got the
point of this yeah
in the upper left um corner or sorry
upper right corner it has the
logo for mario party 3. that's how you
know this was a game from mario party
okay
let's not know wrap the princesses in
the center of the of the
hill though okay oh
i definitely just ran right into that oh
my goodness serpentine serpentine
okay okay okay
oh god oh no i fear my geologic mice
[Laughter]
we ran out of time
that was a struggle that was that was a
struggle
you didn't give up i think that's a
moral victory like a victory of the
spirit
yeah not as good as an actual victory
i know i agree
you guys are full of it full of
superstars
no that's just you rio
you have enough for a large one i am
going to go for a large one
i like that you took the bait because
now you don't have enough for a star
and for those who don't know the the
large oh my gosh
yeah that's a little dangerous for you
dear being in first
place yeah well
we were also going to make sure we uh
showed another board today
so we might just have to leave this game
where ryona's winning
oh no yeah i'm happy to leave this board
right now
but i just planted my big strawberry
all the more reason to leave
oh hey a hidden block there was a one of
one of the cool things about this
this game is that you can save uh so if
you you know something happens between
games
or in the middle of the game rather you
can come back to it right exactly auto
saves at the top of every
turn yeah top of every turn so we had a
game a little while ago that came a
little
a little uh uh contentious
emotional heated um heated that's
heating is good
yeah yes and we thought we would finish
it off
are we are we in a place to do that now
everyone sure yeah
all right all right so let's pause and
get that set up for a moment we've
warmed up enough now
yeah that's the warmer time to jump into
the uh
the real all right here we are
on the space land board on turn 17 of 20
this is i'm really excited because this
was getting pretty intense
we're all playing the same characters as
we were before
and that looks like rob's up yeah let's
take a look at that board
uh you'll notice this ominous counter in
the middle yeah that's not looking good
it uh if you remember this board it was
also from the n64 games
um there's a scary countdown when you
cross that space and then when it comes
to zero
hopefully we'll get to see but uh
i think chances are chances are pretty
high all right
i'm gonna roll
and oh all right well fine a two i got a
two
are you happy now i got a two i think it
worked out pretty well yeah
sure all right i love this board this is
what i would consider a superstar board
i have a lot of really fond memories of
particularly playing on on this board uh
with friends and family
right and this is one of the boards
where the star moves
every time someone gets one so it's
really random and difficult to plan
but there's also a lot of sort of
tactical value to it um
the the star moving means that like the
speed traps which hopefully we'll see in
a minute here
uh yeah like online differently
depending on where the star is and where
everyone else where do i wanna
let's see 32 spaces to the star
but boo's down here so i think i will go
through the game yeah oh no heart one
yeah don't use the boo i mean
boo and i we're real tight
you spent a lot of time in uh dangerous
places yeah
we've spent a lot of time together you
know bonded
he'll do me a favor now and then one of
the things i do i do really appreciate
about this
game is that uh when you come to a fork
in the road or like a choice to use a
key or not
it tells you how many spaces to the star
in either direction you have available
so here it's just 28 to the star because
brandon is just going to go towards the
star but when you get
here you can check all the different
routes and see which one's the
the shortest down to one oh no
one i also have one of these keys so i'm
gonna actually use this to unlock this
gate and see what's behind it
so we'll go here
thank you i love the skeleton key
oh my gosh
what are you doing yes what is this
oh this is chance time chance yeah oh
man this is such a blast from the past
yeah
so the two wheels on the side say who
who is something is going to happen to
and from
and then the middle one says what what
the verb is going to be what you know
they're going to
move coins change stars uh stars
oh my goodness oh no not me this is bad
if birdo
is oh no please no
i don't have a spot everyone else has
one star
in the concentrate if you guys no
we're sick i'm so scared oh man
oh this is
oh no okay
here it goes all right four players the
stakes are very high this time oh
boy oh yeah the snakes don't get
which it says in the top corner there
for mario party too
all right oh my goodness oh why do i
have to go first well you know you know
the strategy right
uh i picked the same color as my dress
yep yeah
does it work yes so basically the
objective of this game
is to pick a pump and hope that you
don't get blown up
i will choose my only color the only
color i'm wearing
i know the strategy of going before you
mean i get to speak pink
uh let's see i'm actually gonna go
are you sure no
oh my god no i think everyone holds
their breath
i really do i think it's an involuntary
reaction
it's gotta be green luigi there's no way
this could go wrong
obviously yeah
the strategy failed
have a nice trip
no i'm gonna stick with pink
oh great
all right oh no well that's ominous good
luck rob
this is when it gets real scary all
right i'm
i'm going yellow because i like yellow
super solid
solid choice oh
i was hoping that yellow would betray
you oh no
you're mean yeah eeny meeny miny
no we're going i'm getting light-headed
[Laughter]
can i breathe again that game is so
tense it's so tense i love it it might
be the tensest thing
i'm so glad they brought it back for
yeah because
that is a classic so fun
nice racing shocking turner all right
okay let's see if i can roll more than a
two that's what i have for items
returns is still a lot of time so i can
make someone else roll short yeah things
can change quite a bit especially during
the last five turns of the map because
the the stakes get raised
yeah all right i'm just
i don't i'm just going to go for it the
blue and red spaces
uh are doubled
but you're gonna land on a versus spot
that's exciting yeah i'm going to land
on a versatile spot but the first
question is do i set a speed trap for
the sniffit patrol and
obviously yes obviously this never goes
wrong
ever i mean it's a rhetorical question
answer's always yes
i mean chances are you're going gonna
trigger it yourself and then we'll see
what happens i love when they revamp
this board is just like all the things
you know that were on the previous board
like the the sniffit police station and
um the little blooper super or spaceship
is
i love that bloopers everything looks so
yeah all right so we're doing a versus
mini game now
and because there's a blue space i got
three coins to start with and then
betting seven seven okay seven okay
comfortable steaks by which you mean
cowardly steak
i mean you're the one that picked it rob
oh no okay
okay this is a very uh very
another tense game i'm going to pass out
soon
basically we're back doing what the shy
guy says
but not too fast because sometimes he
changes his little mind his little shy
mind okay
this this game takes a lot of
concentration
and not rare oh god at home
so quickly come back for me
oh god
as someone who struggles with left and
right this is my least favorite game
you and i have a long history of of
competitiveness when it comes to this
game oh no
he does not talk all right
and there's plenty of time left i'm sure
you guys will be all right if you want
to
secret weapon is that i'm left-handed i
have to think about this way more often
than you right-handers
oh i think that's cheating rob oh no
yes predomination nice work rob
thank you nice work
oh man that was one of my favorites from
the original mario party as well
if we're ever in a pinch and we need
somebody who knows they're left from the
right i'm going to come to you
i'm
you are not doing great that's f thank
you very much karen
i'm just here to point out the facts
let's see what item do i have
oh ice block this is nice unless you
just choose your roll
that's pretty nice i'm going to choose a
10.
a little laugh condescending laughing
thoroughly included but encouraged
i'm surprised you guys wanted to come
back to this game since it's just
putting so hard
look i lost the toss is it too late to
go back to the cake
well it did save so technically we could
that's true that's true
all right i am going to see what i can
do
about my friend boo oh no
oh no i unfortunately don't have enough
money
to steal a star so i think i'm just
going to
try maybe take some coins from luigi no
that's i think that's a fantastic
doesn't have a star and you and i have a
competitive history
so i think at this point we all have a
computer this is
true this is also true
go riona go rio
the thing that we're not telling you at
home is ryona's actually very good at
opening boo off normally but that was
not really his best performance frankly
you know i'm just gonna go this way and
uh
good luck where am i where am i on the
map i don't remember where i'm on the
back
the internal question oh oh no am i on
the back
oh no look at how amazing this canon
looks now though it's so terrifying
so cool i love the upgrades to it and it
just slowly reveals
moves in the path ah which it turns out
is no
good when it does hit it takes away all
your coins
yeah it's devastating pretty brutal
devastating
yeah i'll pay six coins for that that's
that's probably how he afforded his own
satellite
i'll take a five uh so here's a great
example of the
the how many how many spaces to the next
star thing there was six or like
and another great example of what the
speed trap that robset does
i don't like here comes the speeder
don't like it
so if that speed trap hadn't been set
i just realized that if the speed trap
pushes you back to the path of the laser
yeah in both cases
that's right very lucky for me that i
was not already there yeah
okay yeah right this is a coin
collecting another coin collecting one
party three both from mario party 33
yeah well i feel sorry for you guys
[Laughter]
because i'm just gonna swoop up all of
the coins and make you
crash into all of the obstacles i've got
a a tricky spot here because i'm in the
middle of these two i can't
if they're close together i can't really
move oh no oh no oh no but we all get to
keep whatever coins we collect
there are no losers here no you don't
pull this one
hey i'm just you know clearing out the
obstacles for you actually because i'm
such a nice princess
thanks so much okay you're welcome no
it's my pleasure
yep
the three of us together got six coins
i repeat i feel sorry for you that i was
the one driving
yeah me too i also feel sorry you know
us princesses are used to being driven
around and not driving
so how are you so good at it well did
you see how many logs i hit though
no i did not i was trying to pay
attention to nothing logs myself
everyone at home knows everyone at home
knows they're nodding along
wait what i felt the fit of peak coming
on so you got a cursed ice block
oh thank you that bird of laugh is very
good
congrats oh
oh oh one of the things i was talking
about when i say the stakes are raised
during the last five turns they landed
on the same space
so now there's a duel
yes you know my favorite part about this
is is that i don't have anything at
stake right now
how nice i am going to enjoy this
i really appreciate luigi's battle
stance yeah
ready for something ready though look at
those fists
yeah oh my goodness 142 coins good luck
to both of you
see rob now you better not lose
what the heck is this oh i'm
okay i'm on the top screen let's look at
let's
start with that key information
yeah well that was one of the great ones
okay two and three were amazing would
you call it one of these super star wars
yes absolutely hopping hopping
oh my goodness oh does it help to say
hopping out loud rob it does
help say hopping out loud so i remember
what i'm popping
hopping wrong you guys are neck this is
just too intense stopping rob
it backfired backfired
yeah i like the slow and steady approach
that rob is taking
working for him so far i'm also holding
my breath again so i'm really feeling
pretty loud
oh okay just stop talking rob let us no
no no no
okay okay here we go
no no no
no oh god oh gosh why is this
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i don't think i've ever seen anyone have
so many coins in one
game oh and i get plus six too oh my god
yeah it just was a cherry on top
well what about that golden uh pipe that
you have well i can't
use it now what a shame
i'm so sorry for you
that's like adding insult to injury
right there
so as the koopa just explained you have
to when you pass by the bank you have to
deposit some coins and then over lands
and it gets all those coins but
brianna didn't have anything
and whose fault is that that's mine
for that i understood it was physical
let's see i want to take a look at the
board because
i have a warp block and i'm tempted to
use it
and i've we've got a couple people that
are kind of closer to the star than me
so i think it might be time
i think it might be time let's let's
think this through
see the problem is it's a random
opponent so there's a chance that i'll
swap with berto and it won't get me any
closer but
i could swap with brandon
thank you thank you mario party gods
for listening to my plea why must you
hurt me in this way
oh but it's 14 to the star and so you're
not getting there
but you know what i just got an item
mini game so
we'll see maybe it'll have oh yeah if
you could roll extra on the next one
yeah a shot i mean it's the only chance
i have
so little one of those let's go for that
triple
oh no that's not bad that's fine
that's what i meant to do obviously were
you so focused on the balloon you wanted
you didn't even see the balloon in front
of you
no i thought that if i held the button
then i could release it when i was ready
but then i pressed it and she shot the
arrow so
read the instructions you know gosh a
lesson to all of us
10's at least a little helpful here hey
look you're right back where you started
thank you thanks for pointing that out
okay you know no harm no fat
really it only helps me
it only makes her stronger i'm carrying
this rage into this mini game
okay this one i think that piranha
plants have a prominent place
in our hearts yeah afterwards this one's
super simple
but you're trying to collect as much
water
[Laughter]
that's not the purpose of this if you
need a shower go somewhere else
give me rain yes come on no fine this is
fine nope
is the public good if i can try it this
is not fine
come on oh yeah oh man what i think i
love about this is that there's a little
bit of rumble in the controller when
you're
getting water very easy to tell when
you're doing it right yeah that cloud
was really booking it
yeah it was a fast cloud yeah sharp
turns
i don't feel good about that yes very
poorly nice work brandon
what a beautiful strawberry you know
what i'll give you that is a nice
looking strawberry thank you
i'm making a comeback i can feel it
slowly but surely
i mean you somehow
if only you could get to the star if
only i could get to the star
but i have no idea i'm just going to
delight in the fact that riona is three
coins
shy of the star
because
[Laughter]
oh no
there is only one possible answer we all
know what it is
yep yep yep yep or you could wager one
point and she still won't have enough
even if she wins
oh that also would be pretty good that's
what i would have done
but this is funnier yeah i like how many
different strategies people bring into
stuff like
well and if if riona wins this game
which let's be honest
i'm going to the underground if there
was ever an underdog moment
oh okay i mean this is the most like
luigi another like super standard or
super simple rather
oh there things are not voting for our
heroes
all right how good are you at jump rope
guys
moderate i think we should just talk
through the whole
whole game and distract them as much as
possible how are you doing kay how are
things i'm great
you know this is very amusing to me
this this new rivalry born out of this
is going to be one for this
whoa who authorized that
sorry i couldn't help but press the red
button over here
yeah vengeance i'm the best that was a
very
very good come from behind moment
rihanna i applaud you
what are you talking about i was always
going to win uh-huh
yeah well we'll see now she has enough
for the star
it may be the last turn but the game's
not over until it's over
it's true very true oh you just got all
your coins back
and then some
you know what i'm gonna do you know for
the sake of the people at home i'm
really glad you get to show this off
yeah cause this is a really nice item oh
so nice now
i just wish i was the one that got to
use it
and now the star is gonna be in a
different place so much for my strategy
too bad brandon
[Laughter]
you and i are going to have a talk later
[Laughter]
will it be a loud talk potentially
i think the moral of this is you can't
keep a good plumber down
i think the moral of this is i should
have used kay's strategy of not wagering
enough coins to help you get them
yeah i mean sometimes i have good ideas
it's true
hey
you know what i just done
oh no i have so many fun memories of
just playing
mario party with my family at the
holidays and
i'm so excited to play this with them
this year
yeah growing up with this game was
definitely a big highlight
were these old games oh my gosh now now
you give me the time
oh but hey oh hey oh oh but hey oh
hey don't luigi
look who hey
[Music]
[Laughter]
star no she stole the other one see it's
part of my grand plan no i don't want to
uh
you know make you do all the work
and then steal the star you had this
whole thing mapped out from the
beginning right
yes in fact i have and look i'm going to
be one away from the star if only we
played one more turn
i told you everything can turn around in
just a minute it can
and you can change the number of turns
you play as well hey why don't we add
five more turns
just just to give me a fair chance
unfortunately you can't do it once the
game is starting
dang it hold on you know what you must
do oh no
oh well brandon
i have never done anything cruel to you
come on princess solidarity come on
i don't know you
[Laughter]
we're in space this is my territory you
know i
i probably deserved that
but it still stings
hooray rosalina
man the star theft industry is getting a
big boost this year
you know what boo and i are going to
have to have a chat
i'm disappointed uh coin
coin thing okay this is where it really
changes oh boy okay let's see we got
nope one number you know what that's
great
yeah it's all the same to me yeah
okay rob mister i have 175 coins in my
back pocket
i like this one oh this one's hard oh no
this one requires thinking and strategy
not my strong suit so there's a bunch of
fruit here
and there's bee hives and you choose
whether you want one or two things to
come down into your basket one two don't
want to be honest
five six seven eight nine left
i don't know what that means can i take
some fruit and go
there's also a timer so like if you can
strategize within 10 seconds
you're in good shape yeah i don't know
how to strategize this way
[Laughter]
oh no okay i'm in good shape too
this is good my strategy is chaos
i approve oh no no no no
no enjoy those 175 coins
i will i'm gonna make them into a big
pile and roll around on them
too bad you won't have any stars to add
to that pile
you don't know
[Laughter]
i'm seeing a different side of cat here
i don't know what's happening to me
right now
nintendo treehouse live what do people
mean yeah
okay oh no this won't blow up in my face
okay
mm-hmm yeah really nice we'll take it
we'll take it
i want you to remember what i'm doing
for you in this moment
oh i want you to remember what princess
solidarity looks
like you are wise and merciful
i've always been dependent
the kindness of bees
kind the kindness of beef
[Laughter]
okay let's get this over with
we're picking fruit we're having fun
yeah it's a lot of fun mm-hmm
nothing i take my eyes off that apple
like it's just so shiny
okay delicious okay okay okay okay okay
oh
oh oh dear i don't know what's gonna
happen yeah we're gonna try this
yeah that wasn't a good a good move i
think you were pretty much screwed
either way
oh thanks for playing princess soldier
you know someone has to come out on top
there is not lots of solidarity
that's how parties work i was here first
every party has a superstar that's true
oh that felt good
[Laughter]
it feels good to win that's good yeah i
had it coming
i mean it's not a star but it's
something final
final mini
oh and i jumped off right away we all
did that's a that's a great sign
this is going to go great we just showed
what not to do
so you know i think we'll be good now
yeah okay that could possibly happen
we understand completely how to not play
my strategy here
is don't fall but also chaos
i failed strategy number one chaos did
not work for me
do not friends what
oh no wow luigi's like a predator here
i do colors good oh
is toad showing us what he's going to do
i guess what he's going to do
i i miss that entire oh oh no i have no
oh oh saved how did you
[Laughter]
see you just displayed the strategy that
i was trying to do
before i just bounced off of someone's
head and landed in the water
i wanted to show how you would have won
that game
princess solidarity
so there's some bonus stars that got
handed out at the very end so it's
this is where everything changes you
know
shopping bonus oh no who bought who
bought the most items
i think i was probably don't think about
it i think it was me yeah well done
ryona woo hoo
okay victory we'll take it i suppose
this has to be me though right with my
bad dice rolls
i don't know about that congratulations
rob
thank you okay all right
all right i finally got a star this time
you're the superstar in our hearts
okay unfortunately it's going to come
down to brandon and riona i think isn't
it
we'll see
brandon i met that one
what a wonderful party i'm a no loser
i am super i'm going to clap a massive
performance well done
well i think that's all the time we have
thank you everyone for tuning in to
watch us play
mario party superstars i hope you had as
much fun as we did
um stay tuned coming up next we'll have
some uh monster hunter stories
two wings of ruin bye